what i'm saying for me is that that's
not a diagnosis
that i want to make a part of my
identity i hear you
no i'm just uh yeah so and you know what
the
it's funny because i talk in a lot of
these um
uh talks that i do i mean i just gave a
mental health talk to uh the
american correctional association that's
like 1500 uh
correctional officers right and talking
about my mom's experience talking about
my experience growing up
offering my perspective and thoughts
about things and
and one of the things that i talk about
is
language and how and
and and how language is i mean the
mental health field the psychiatry in
particular
uh has come so far i mean my mom's thing
was we have to destigmatize
and you even see it now that nfl
football ad was so great about
you know destigmatizing it and
everything else but in a um
not but also in a way that
project of de-stigmatizing has worked in
a lot of
areas maybe not in all areas but you
know if you go to
if you go to indiana where my wife is
from people are more than comfortable
talking about
their medications you know and oh i've
got to go to cvs to get my medication oh
i have
and and somehow it's like it's a little
bit more
socially acceptable now for people to
use that phrase and that should be
encouraging to anybody who
has an issue that like oh there's a lot
of places in this world you can go
where you are uh where where
where someone with that diagnosis is
fully understood and accepted to be
a total human being and it's not going
to
uh limit your your life and that's
exciting
that's exciting but the vocabulary of
psychiatry
actually in a lot of ways is meant to be
used between
physicians and uh between physicians
and the drug world in pharmaceutical
world
and the nursing community and
administrative people
and there's a lot of people for whom the
the vocabulary of mental illness
is really efficient and
you know proper and throwing everything
else but it totally up a lot of
people
you know actual human beings who are
actually being diagnosed because
in a lot of ways it's like uh it's like
a death sentence
for people it feels like a brand like
branding you know it's like this is this
you're labeled this is who you are
well that but also just just
you know they they uh they call one of
the words is uh well patient
your mental health patient but you're
also uh they use the word sufferer
oh this person's a mental health
sufferer and you're like jesus christ
how's anybody supposed to develop like
wellness in their life
if they're constantly thinking of
themselves indefinitely
as a patient or indefinitely as a
sufferer
like that vocabulary is not helpful that
people think it is not
sufferer is not something people want to
associate themselves with
oh i am a survivor and recovery
and like those words can be very very
helpful
and very empowering and very useful
at particularly certain phases of
people's uh
discovery of their own like wellness
strategy
but um but for a lot of people it makes
it so they don't want to get it
diagnosed they don't want to go to the
doctor
they don't want to consider uh the types
of
medications that might be available to
them they don't they don't want to
consider it because
they just don't like the vibe and to me
the community can do itself
a big service by acknowledging that its
communication skills are like the
lagging
thing in their progress and so what i
was saying was in terms of stigma
it actually is still there in a way like
in in if you have your druthers
pick that diagonal you know talk about
that diagnosis or not
um i get a lot of positive feedback when
i say to people when they ask me what
you're asking me
like you don't have to and relative to
my kids relative to anybody
you don't have to tell anyone
what your diagnosis is
you know first thing the willingness the
bravery it takes to
to put yourself up for some kind of
evaluation to see if if some sort of
diagnosis is
you know appropriate for you that takes
courage it's terrifying for people to do
that
um and then but doing that and then
getting the diagnosis
that's just the doctor's half of the
equation you have to accept
the diagnosis and if you're willing you
know
if the diagnosis isn't right for you and
you don't accept it you know
good for you that you went through a
process where you are more armed with
information than you were beforehand
if you get a diagnosis and you're
willing to accept it
because it's helpful to you uh then
that's great too yeah but then when it
comes time to
sharing your process and your experience
some people aren't like us
some people don't feel good some
people's work environment for example
is not conducive if you were to you know
you may be legally protected
but it might make people uncomfortable
because they have some who knows what so
you people have to decide for themselves